this morning the 212 page state of AI
report 2024 was released and as I did
last year I want to bring you just the
highlights yes I read it all and it's
been going 6 years and it gives a
powerful framework around which I can
also weave in some of the most
interesting developments of the past few
days so now that I am done with the
gratuitous special effects courtesy of a
new P AI tool that I upgraded my account
to bring you guys here is the report the
report has been going 6 years and it's
from Air Street Capital these are of
course my highlights you will find
plenty more if you read the full report
yourself Linked In the description but
this first highlight and this page I
suspect initially read open ai's Reign
of Terror came to an end and the authors
and they can correct me if they are
watching probably had to edit that with
a comma until when 01 came out
essentially this page is stating that
models like Claude 3.5 Sonic grock 2
Gemini 1.5 caught up with GPT 4 all
models are converging they thought
because of the heavy overlaps in
pre-training Data before we get to the
research section though I covered their
2023 predictions in a video from about a
year ago their predictions are on the
left and their rating of their own
predictions is on the right there was
one prediction that they rated as having
failed that I think is pretty harsh they
said the Gen AI scaling craze would see
a group spend spending over a billion
dollars to train a single large scale
model and the rating was let's give that
another year but just yesterday we got
this from the information which is that
open ai's projected 2024 costs for
training a model is $3 billion note that
that does not include research compute
amortization as in training miniature
models to see what works this is fullon
training of Frontier models I would be
pretty surprised if the full 01 model if
you count the base model generator and
the fine-tuned final model didn't cost
at least $1 billion that report in the
information by the way said that open
aai likely won't turn a profit until
2029 according to internal sources oh
and if you thought 1 billion or even 3
billion was quite a lot for training
llms training chatbots you might think
of them well how about almost 10 billion
a year in 2026 note that doesn't include
the playing around research compute cost
of more than $5 billion in that same
year just imagine how many experiments
or tinkering about $5 billion can bring
you the next highlight for me was the
section on multimodality and meta's
movie gen we can't actually play about
with the model which is why I haven't
done a whole separate video on it but I
will play this 5-second extract because
it is impressive how it can produce
audio at the same time as video
[Applause]
you might have caught there the chainsaw
sound effect when she was doing the
garden and the car racing sounds as the
car was racing on the carpet to be
honest compared to reading the movie gen
paper I found it more fun to play about
with tools like P AI which are available
now and all you have to do is upload an
image and then pick a peer effect like
melt or explode or Squish and you get
these amazing little Clips look at
mudang here picked up and squished or my
AI Insiders on patreon the logo look at
this boom there is the full screen
explosion and I think that is pretty
cool now of course I'm not going to
ignore the fact that the Nobel Prize in
physics Was Won by a pair of neural
network scientists AI scientists and
likewise sir Demis hassabis of Google
Deep Mind Fame c-on the Nobel Prize in
chemistry for Alpha fold one commentator
said this represents AI eating science
and it's hard to disagree with that in
fact now think of it I wonder what the
odds in prediction markets are for most
Nobel prizes in The Sciences in the
2030s being won by people involved in AI
obviously some of you may argue that the
AI itself should win the prize actually
that reminds me on a complete tangent is
kind of related to Google deepmind I saw
this job advert for Google deepmind here
it is it's a new one it's a research
scientist job position but you need to
have where is it down here you need to
have a deep intro interest in machine
cognition and Consciousness so maybe the
prospect of AI winning the Nobel Prize
Isn't So far-fetched I will also note
that almost all of these figures have
issued stringent warnings about the
future of AI so Demis tabis comparing
the threat of AI going wrong to nuclear
war John hoteld has recently issued a
warning about the world turning into
something like 1984 because of AI
controlling the narrative and of course
Jeffrey Hinton has issued a myriad
warnings about the inherent superiority
of artificial intelligence compared to
human intelligence I watched the
interviews that he did today and
yesterday and I did pick out these two
or three highlights first he is proud of
his former student Ilia satova firing
samman I'm particularly proud of the
fact that one of my students fired
samman and I think I better leave it
there and leave it for questions can you
please elaborate on your comment earlier
on the call of about Sam Altman open AI
was set up with a big emphasis on safety
its primary objective was to develop
artificial general intelligence and
ensure that it was safe one of my former
students in yova was the chief scientist
and over time it turned out that Sam
Alman was much less concerned with
safety than with
profits and I think that's um
unfortunate in a nutshell though here
was his warning War most of the top
researchers I know believe that AI will
become more intelligent than people they
vary on the time scales a lot of them
believe that that will happen sometime
in the next 20 years some of them
believe it will happen sooner some of
them believe it will take much longer
but quite a few good researchers believe
that sometime in the next 20 years AI
will become more intelligent than us and
we need to think hard about what happens
then um my guess is probably happens
sometime between 5 and 20 years from now
it might be longer there's a very small
Chan it'll be sooner and we don't know
what's going to happen then so if you
look around there are very few examples
of more intelligent things being
controlled by less intelligent things
which makes you wonder whether when AI
gets smarter than us it's going to take
over control one thing I am pretty
confident in is that a world of superior
artificial intelligence will be a hell
of a lot weirder than R1 here's an
example from page 54 about brain LM
which I'll be honest I hadn't even heard
of I did read the brain LM paper after
this though because this line caught my
eye this model can be fine-tuned to
predict clinical variables EG age and
anxiety disorders better than other
methods in simple terms it can read your
brain activity and predict better than
almost any other method whether you have
for example Mental Health challenges
that is not actually something I knew
existed and the paper is also very
interesting not only by the way is brain
LM inspired by natural language models
it leverages a Transformer based
architecture they mask future states
allowing the model to do self supervis
training and predict what comes next if
that rings a bell with enough data and
pre-training brain LM can predict future
brain States and decode cognitive
variables and possibly most impactfully
although other two are pretty impactful
it can do in silico peration analysis in
other words imagine testing medications
for depression in Silicon on gpus rather
than initially with patients brain LM
has the ability to simulate brain
responses in a biologically meaningful
manner the next highlight is a fairly
quick one and you may have heard of
alphafold 3 from Google deepmind about
predicting the structure of proteins DNA
and more but I didn't know that there
was chai one from chai Discovery backed
by open AI which is an open-source
alternative nor did I know that its
performance in certain domains is
comparable or Superior to Alpha fold 3
Alpha fold 3 don't forget has not been
fully open- sourced one other highlight
I'm going to pick out on page 96 I'm
going to choose not because it's
particularly revealing but because it
exemplifies the kind of stacking
accelerations that we're experiencing
the chart below shows the generations of
Nvidia Data Center gpus and you can see
the number of months between releases is
gradually on average declining you may
wonder about the Next Generation which
is apparently the Reuben r100 which is
going to come in late 20125 so yes we
have the release dates coming closer and
closer together on average but also as
you can see from the right line the
accelerating number of teraflops within
each GPU you can think of this as
charting the thousands of trillions of
floating Point operations or
calculations per second per GPU that's
already fairly accelerated right until
you learn that the number of gpus that
we're clustering not just in one data
center but combining data centers is
also massively increasing and of course
the amount of money that people are
spending on these gpus and that's all
before we consider the algorithmic
efficiencies within models like the 01
Series this is why and I've said this
before on the channel I think the next 2
years of progress is pretty much baked
in I did a massive analysis video on my
patreon but suffice to say the next
10,000 x of scale is pretty much baked
in which brings me to the next highlight
and it's a fairly quick one but China
wants some of that scale I just thought
you guys might enjoy this quick anecdote
given that h100s aren't allowed to be
sold to China but a Malaysian broker had
a way of sticking to those rules kind of
Nvidia coordinated the rental
installation and activation of servers
based in a Malaysian Town adjacent to
the Singapore border Nvidia inspectors
checked the servers there and left
shortly afterward the servers were
whisked away to China via Hong Kong
depending on the modality China it seems
to me is between 3 and 12 months behind
the frontier but not much more than that
I'm not drawing any conclusions it was
just interesting for me to read this and
hopefully for you too speaking of
renting and costs there is this chart
going around about the 100x drop in
price of Frontier models from open AI or
with anthropic a 60x drop from the cost
of Claude 3 Opus to claw 3 Hau but I've
never believed those kind of drops
because we're not comparing like for
like in simple bench performance for
example Opus is just streets ahead of
Hau it's not even close but on page 110
the report had this comparison which for
me feels a bit more accurate to what has
been achieved and it is still dramatic
even comparing quote the same model gini
1.5 Pro from launch to second half of
2024 it's a 76% price cut likewise for
Gemini 1.5 flash it's an 86% price cut
this remember is for roughly equivalent
if not Superior performance so if we try
to keep the average bar of performance
the same that feels about right an 80%
cut in price for the same actual
performance we wouldn't want to
extrapolate too far but if that rate of
price cut carried on for one two 5 years
it would be a wild world we would live
in and yes by the way it would be a
world largely dominated I think still by
Transformers as we've seen with brain LM
and 01 the full capabilities of
Transformers are still being discovered
and they represent a 3/4 market share
next highlight is a quick one on
copyright and we all know probably that
openai transcribed millions of hours of
YouTube videos to power its whisper
model did you know that Runway ML and
Nvidia also Mass scraped YouTube but I
thought some of you might be interested
in the fact that people are trying to
create business models now like Calo
networks so that creators can sell their
YouTube videos to be scraped basically
get paid for what's already happening
for free I know there are plenty of
YouTube creators who wouldn't mind a
tiny slice of that 100 billion in
Revenue that open AI are projecting
however we probably should bear in mind
Mark Zuckerberg's Words which are that
creators and Publishers overestimate the
value of their work for training AI
obviously it's too long to go into here
but I think 01 slightly justifies this
claim it seems to me and obviously this
is a very early take but as long as
there is some data within the model that
pertains to the kind of reasoning that
must be done to answer a particular
problem the 01 method will find it
doesn't necessarily need abundant
examples just some I will likely not be
making that point though I'm just
wondering if anyone offers me a check
for scraping my old YouTube videos by
the way it's not just videos teams are
working on getting authors paid for
their Works use by AI companies now I've
just had a thought that if it were
possible somehow to reverse engineer the
data sources that were most responsible
for model performance I don't think any
of these companies would have an
incentive to find out those data sources
while it's all just this Mass aggregated
data scraped from the internet there's
little kind of clear responsibility to
pay this person or that I'm basically
saying that the re Arch talent that is
probably most able to do the kind of
engineering necessary to ascertain the
most useful unique sources of data for
the models is the very same Talent least
incentivized to do that research anyway
speaking of kind of externalities like
copyright payment how about
environmental effects well all of these
companies as I have covered before made
various pledges saying that they're
going to be completely carbon neutral I
should probably reflect on my use of the
word pledges there they're more kind of
aspirational brainstorming notes without
making things too complicated power
usage because of AI among other things
is going to Skyrocket now bear with me
though that doesn't matter according to
Eric Schmidt formerly CEO of Google
because we weren't going to hit our
targets anyway my own opinion is that
we're not going to hit the climate goals
anyway because we're not organized to do
it we're not and the way to do it is
with the things that we're talking about
now and yes the yes the the needs in
this area will be a problem but I'd
rather bet on AI solving the problem
than constraining it and having the
problem now just in case that doesn't
reassure you here is samman and Ilia
SATA back when they still worked
together saying that AI will solve
climate change I hate I don't want to
say this because it it it climate change
is so serious and so hard of a problem
but I think once we have a really
powerful super intelligence addressing
climate change will not be particularly
difficult for a system like that yeah we
can even explain
[Music]
how here's how you solve climate change
you need a very large amount of carbon C
of efficient carbon capture you need the
energy for the carbon cupture you need
the technology to build it and you need
to build a lot of it if you can
accelerate the scientific progress which
is something that a powerful AI could do
we could get to a very Advanced carbon
capture much faster we could get to a
very cheap power much faster could get
to cheaper manufacturing much faster now
combine those three cheap power cheap
manufacturing Advanced carbon capture
now you build lots of them and now you
sucked out all this all the excess CO2
from the atmosphere you know if you
think about a system where you can say
tell me how to make a lot of clean
energy cheaply with with one addition
that not only you ask it to tell it you
ask it to do
it of course I don't want to be too
factious AI genuinely does lead to
efficiencies which reduce energy usage I
just thought that it might be worth
flagging that until a super intelligent
AI solves climate change AI data centers
might raise your electricity bills and
increase the risk of blackout for many
of you this will be just a trivial
externality for others pretty annoying
drawing to an end now just three more
points the first is a quick one and it's
basically this in a nutshell
jailbreaking has not been solved there
was page after page after page proving
that many many many jailbreaking
techniques still work stealth attacks
sleeper agents instruction hierarchies
being compromised within hours and on
and on and on I just wanted to summarize
for anyone who wasn't up to date with
this that jailbreaking has definitely
not been solved it brings to mind early
last year when some researchers thought
that jailbreaking was essentially a
solved problem amade to his credit said
at the time this is 2023 we are finding
new jailbreaks every day people
jailbreak claw they jailbreak the other
models I'm deeply concerned that in 2 to
3 years that would be 1 to 2 years from
now a jailbreak could be life or death
but as page 203 points out are we
focused on the wrong harms and this was
such an interesting chart on the right
of the actual misuses of gen that I try
to find the original Source I will say
as a slight critique of this report they
do make finding the original sources a
bit harder than I would have thought but
anyway it was this June paper from
Google deepmind generative AI misuse a
taxonomy of tactics and insights from
Real World data so in short these are
the actual misuses that are happening
now with Gen AI I'll put the definitions
up on screen but you can see that the
most frequent one is impersonating
people like those robocalls in New
Hampshire pretending to be Joe Biden but
obviously not being from him or
generating non-consensual intimate
images obviously the chart when we get
AGI and as I artificial super
intelligence might look very different
but for 2024 these are the current harms
last of course I had to end on the
reports predictions for next year and I
do have one slight critique of these
predictions there are a lot of un
quantitative words thrown in Frontier
Labs will Implement meaningful changes
to data collection practices well who
defines meaningful lawmakers will worry
that they've overreached with the EU AI
Act this one is more firm an open source
alternative to open AI 01 surpasses it
across a range of reasoning benchmarks
that one I'm going to go with probably
not that's a close one I think end of
2025 it might get really close but 01 is
going to be something quite special even
01 preview is already Yes open AI have
given a lot of hints about how they did
it but I will stick my neck out and say
that an open- Source alternative won't
surpass 01 maybe llama 4 mid to late
next year get gets close but I don't
think surpasses It Anyway back to
subjective words we've got Challengers
failing to make any meaningful Dent well
what does that mean in nvidia's Market
position levels of investment in
humanoid robots will Trail off does that
mean go down or just increase less
quickly I don't think levels of
investment in humanoid robots will go
down for sure I think it will keep going
up nine is obviously a very firm
prediction which is a research paper
generated by an AI scientist is accepted
at a major ml conference or Workshop I'm
going to say no to that one so that one
was a clear objective prediction and I'm
going to take the other side of it I
give you one quick reason why and you
can let me know what you think in the
comments but I think the authors of the
paper will have to make it clear that an
AI wrote it for ethical reasons and then
the conference will likely reject it
even if it's a good paper because it was
done by AI That's even assuming it's
good enough for a proper major ml
conference which I don't think it would
be not in 2025 2027 very different story
and again we have the language a video
game based around interacting with Gen
AI based elements will achieve breakout
status well what does that mean before I
make my own cheeky prediction here's how
I ended last year's video now if I'm
criticizing them it would be remiss of
me not to end the video with my own
prediction I predict that a model will
be released in the next year that will
break state-of-the-art benchmarks across
at least four different modalities
simultaneously I would claim that was
passed with Gypsy 40 in May which broke
certain benchmarks across text domains
and in audio Vision understanding and
other domains but what's my prediction
which I think at the very least is
quantitative that open ai's valuation
will double again next year abson and
invasion of Taiwan by China when you
combine the 01 method with a GPT 5 or
oion scale model amazing things will
happen and I think the world will hear
about it thank you so much for watching
would' love to see you over on patreon
but regardless have a wonderful day